I'm so happy you guys are enjoying the
doctor react series please subscribe if
you're enjoying the videos I jumped into
the comment section and I hear you loud
and clear code black is up next an
influx of patients so great at the
different hospitals that I work there
were different definitions of code
followed by a different color for
example code blue generally meant that
someone's heart stopped or they weren't
breathing rapid response med something
code pink sometimes meant that a baby
was abducted from the newborn nursery
code black generally referred to like a
terrorist threat or some kind of crime
going on I've never heard this type of
definition from this show but it does
make sense hospitals get overcrowded
especially in busy areas like Los
Angeles I'm excited to watch this your
mama knows when you're lying crying or
dying and it's not only my job to teach
you right from wrong but to make sure
you don't leave here in three years
thinking you can do no wrong one of the
biggest things you have to do as a
doctor is learn that there's a lot you
can do wrong I'm talking about over
treating over diagnosing patients that's
truly a health hazard that most people
don't even think about so I love this
nurse and frankly I'd love this actor so
I'm super excited to see him in the show
the most famous true Hospital real
estate in the nation
well mergency medicine was born where
the Secret Service preserved the trauma
bed for the President of the United
States when he
you know fabulous this is trauma one
angels for Mari you are not under any
circumstances allowed to kill a guest in
my house I love this orientation this is
so gay I've worked in numerous hospitals
where the ER was in a part of town where
there was a lot of gang-related
activities and literally people would
walk into the hospital or get thrown out
of a car with a gunshot wound and there
was one time I literally got a patient
that crawled into the emergency room
bleeding from his femoral artery so I
had to grab a glove stick my finger into
his femoral artery and pull him to the
bed and get the whole process started
with the trauma team I remember that
because my hands were so covered in
blood at least up to my elbows that I
was like oh man I have to wash this off
really quickly because that's the first
step of infection control is to wash
your hands I left the trauma scene in
the trauma Bay and walked to one of the
nearest sinks to wash my hands properly
because the situation was being taken
care of by a lot of doctors and then I
realized I was tracking blood all across
the hospital so the maintenance staff
looked at me with these angry eyes and I
was like I'm so sorry I didn't mean to
make a mess but literally they had to
clean up my bloody footsteps I traveled
halfway across the hospital to go wash
my hands it's part of life it's scary
but it's part of life
all right you get over there the side
and push it those legs one two three so
this is very realistic I know it looks
like they're being rough and they're
kicking the patient out of the SUV but
that's true because you literally have a
seconds before the person completely
bleeds out and dies especially from the
carotid artery plugging the wound
obviously is the first absolute they're
doing a great job I'm assuming they
still feel of pulse cuz they said that
the artery was still wiggling so right
now the most important thing is to fluid
resuscitate this person meaning to give
as much fluids as you can with two
large-bore IVs large-bore meaning thick
IV so they can deliver a lot of fluids
very quickly and then it's to obviously
give them blood back donated blood that
we have in the hospital from the blood
bank and give them as much blood as we
can and in the short period of time but
there's dr. Hardy's assistance
I'll be transfuser type and cross-match
blood because it takes time to type and
cross someone's blood so therefore you
want to give them blood that's
universally considered donor blood which
is Oneg ative blood come on let's go
find you an attending to annoy honestly
this is so accurate because at times the
hospital's busy you have to find a
doctor to shadow or learn firm or follow
around and it is sometimes unorganized
like this especially when he gets busy
what's your name Ariel I'm dr. wash and
the truth is we don't know why your
father's unconscious and I can't learn
anything I hear the dark so with your
permission I want to take him inside and
I promise you I will tell you everything
I know as soon as I know okay very good
doctor-patient relationship I found
myself very often in an emergency room
having very serious conversations like
that and I found like that yields the
best results so even in dire situations
when a family is hysterical like that
the more honest I was with them and I
was brutally honest at times saying that
these treatments aren't gonna help your
father mother whoever I was talking
about at the time and I would apologize
I would say I'm sorry I'm being brutally
honest right now but I want you to make
the best decision with the limited
amount of time we have and people
respected that they appreciated that
because in reality nobody wants them to
lie to them nobody wants false promises
that's your evaluation
patient unconscious low BP warm
extremities in spinal shock no
additional examination
that's pretty textbook pretty textbook
huh yeah okay what about you dr. Jessica
with a way that this attending is
teaching while trying to actively save
the patient's life is very accurate like
I feel like I'm in the hospital as a
resident learning it's very accurate
this is exactly how it happens she's not
giving the patient worse care which is
also educating with pressure in a
time-sensitive situation to the
residents excellent excellent
recreation six five four is normal brain
function one one one is the lowest he's
framed in that poor kid oh he was
confused that I didn't understand it yes
called expressive aphasia that's word
Sally sounds right to him the words come
out all tossed around
yeah expressive aphasia is really
interesting it's also known as Broca's
aphasia and that happens if you have
damage to the left front frontal area of
your brain so that can happen in car
accidents it can happen in traumatic
illnesses also strokes basically what
happens is in your mind you know what
you want to say and it's you think
you're saying the right words but when
it comes out you're saying completely
different words and the way that I
memorize this when I was studying and
learning about it was boca means mouth
in Spanish see it was like what's coming
out of your mouth is wrong TPA is a kind
of miracle drug that has the potential
to bust the clot up and reverse the
stroke but only if there's no actual
bleeding yet in the brain we're gonna
need a scan to know for sure this is the
one part about this that's pretty
inaccurate so most hospitals have stroke
protocols when a patient even comes in
with remotely similar symptoms to a
stroke and they instantly go to a cat
scan they instantly get blood work drawn
you instantly page the internal medicine
or family medicine residents to follow
stroke protocol we instantly call the
neurologist and get the robot out and
all of this happens right away because
again you have a small time of window
that you could actually give the TPA so
it's about the fastest fastest way you
can get things done never is it
sustaining a bedside having
conversations of oh let's get the CT
scan and see if there's any bleeding
going on no he's fine
oh she's only lying till tomorrow
someone called Child and Family Services
to come get her yeah but yeah I like
guys who could be housed it gets worse
he's an organ donor transplant team is
on the way
let me come wait for CFS after tena this
is definitely the most medically
accurate show I've seen in such a long
time I don't know why I'm getting
excited about it but it just it's very
accurate these conversations happen in
this matter the father died Ariel well
technically technically it's a a brain
death sure he's not dead no no that's
what I mean is machines are keeping his
body at a state of are you saying I'm
trying to explain to you you're not what
happened just giving you to me sorry
giving it to you straight so he's dead
but text me not really right I wanna see
if it was I've had conversations like
this again the more brutally honest you
can be at least in the beginning that's
usually the best policy my general
strategy is to get as much of the
information out there console them as
much as I can if they become hysterical
get upset telling you to shut up
tell you to leave never get offended
because what they say in those moments
that's not who they are as people
they're going through a moment of shock
emotional shock I'll leave them alone in
the room with maybe someone watching
them a nurse or someone else but me
because I'm the one who gave the bad
news give them some time and then come
see them when some time has gone by and
pretty much every time that I've done
this conversation they apologize we hug
I understand that they've just lost a
family member
I've gone through that in my life with
my mom I've actually had to ask
residents to stop doing CPR on my mom so
I know what this feels like and
sometimes people just need a moment to
themselves they need to not see the
person who just gave them the bad news
so it's okay to be the bad person leave
come back transplant things and Ralph
I want to tell you how fabulous you look
right now I do know I want to tell you
that but then it do it I look like if I
strap to the bow of the ship interesting
about the transplant team they are
skilled set of surgeons that come in and
basically take the organs as soon as the
time of death is called actually when I
was doing my training when I was on the
surgical unit I was one of the people
that was put in a room with the
transplant team to call the time of
death you cannot start to operate on the
patient taking out the organs harvesting
the organs what-have-you until the
person is completely dead so we had to
stand there until I didn't feel a pulse
and my exam was negative there's a lot
of pressure and there was a time where
there wasn't a pulse then he came back
so I had to say well you know weights
and it was a lot of pressure on me being
a young doctor but I wanted to do what
was right by the patient and waited
until the heart completely stopped'
patient had no pain response and only
then did we begin taking out the organs
so they could save someone else's life
don't do that you don't need any more
than a flame believe me have you looked
at yourself in the mirror lately I love
their relations I love you so much I
want to there was a recent article
whether or not it's okay for doctors to
hug patients and other co-workers I
thought it was insane because if we're
gonna get to the state of where we're
not allowed to make physical contact
with people humans crave physical
contact I'm not talking about
inappropriate physical contact I'm
talking about moments like that where
you need encouragement where you need a
hug even most recently I had like an 84
year old patient that was going through
a difficult moment in her life and I
spent an hour with her a visit we talked
about all the things going on we treated
her medical conditions she became very
emotional and cried and asked for a hug
of course I'm gonna hug her worst part
is the headache I live above the boiler
room in my building the noise just keeps
cracking my head open
you can give me for that nine months
pregnant that's not a whole lot we can
do other thing to be title off I've
tried that doesn't work using again
excuse me Mario scores the inside your
arm oil track marks right none of your
damn business
bad bedside manner obviously I've never
seen a more aggressive resident in
questioning a patient you're gonna get
the patient angry whether or not you're
right or wrong
it could bring up old feelings or old
habits that the patient had that can
make them very emotional they're gonna
disconnect they're not gonna follow what
you're saying
no one's winning here by you doing that
shame on you sir your son has a
collapsed lung we're gonna help him how
could you know that if a Norwegian kid
can't breathe it's a pneumothorax
it's a genetic predisposition I've never
heard of that a Norwegian child having a
pneumothorax I'm learning something from
this show I'm gonna look this up after
work actually let's look it up right now
together I'm curious what pops up here a
significant fraction of families with
familial spontaneous pneumothorax have
mutations in the gene the fact that
she's just guessing that this child has
a pneumothorax without a physical exam
is a little crazy for me diesel fumes oh
my god what what if he lives on top of a
boiler room carbon monoxide poisoning
can mimic flu symptoms she said she
lived above a boiler right oh my god
Mario it gives you no common symptoms of
carbon monoxide poisoning is feeling
sleepy having a headache fatigue and the
treatment is breathing in oxygen for the
c-section rate sometimes you gotta get
cowboy right
okay very quickly I want you to reach
your hand inside as fast as you can
carefully feel for the baby yes these
are very crude instructions but I guess
in an emergency this is what they need
to do it feels like they're making a
rash decision here in doing a c-section
like this with someone who's not a
trained operator there's so many
mistakes that can happen I don't know
know what the right answer here is how
about suturing the patient back up so
she doesn't bleed to death
hi i'm vanessa i'm area hello the organs
were used to safer
yeah
okay powerful moment when you know you
had to lose your father but it saved
another person's life code black in the
books this show pleasantly surprised me
I feel like all the other shows I've
watched so far were written by a
Hollywood person and then a doctor
contributed some medical knowledge to it
as opposed to this one it felt like it
was written by a doctor and then a
Hollywood person injected some drama
into it it was a good show I mean it was
feel-good it was medically accurate
where it needed to be the interpersonal
relationships were accurate I'm excited
for the show I think it has a lot of
potential if you guys like this show
please let me know
give me some episodes to watch because
I'm so down to watch more of code black
go ahead and smash that subscribe and
like button down below as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]